und es geht weiter es geht weiter mit
berlin es geht weiter mit diesem corpus
delicti möchte ich fast sagen dass der
stimmzettel zur landtagswahl zur
senatswahl vergangenen herbst das war
der tag an dem der bundestag gewählt
wurde in ganz deutschland und in dem an
dem tag wurde in berlin ebenfalls ein
neues abgeordnetenhaus gewählt und sie
erinnern sich vielleicht daran dass es
noch mehr so überall eigentlich um 18
uhr den gongschlag gab und die
wahllokale in ganz deutschland schlossen
fast in ganz deutschland in berlin
durfte weiter gewählt werden weil es
zahlreiche pannen gegeben hat marcel ute
ihr thema für den heutigen abend das
wahl-debakel das wahlchaos aus berlin
von berlin ende september 20 21 das war
chaos das sich ja bereits auch im
vorfeld abgezeichnet hatte er hat dass
das darf man nicht vergessen weil er
hinterher erzählt wurde ja der also
niemand konnte damit rechnen dass dieses
und jenes nicht funktioniert man ist
zunächst einmal hingegangen wissend dass
wir eine bundestagswahl eine
landtagswahl und eine kommunalwahl am
gleichen tag haben plus einen
volksentscheid nicht dass es das nicht
schon mal gegeben hat das hat sich
glaubt 94 auch schon mal gegeben in
berlin dass wir also händelbar damals
sondern hat gleichzeitig auch noch ein
marathon auf dem dach gewesen das war
schon per se nicht sonderlich sinnvoll
dann war man offensichtlich nicht in der
lage ist tatsächlich mal so zu
organisieren dass die wahlzettel auch am
tag so wie sich das gehört
beziehungsweise im vortrag ausgegeben
werden an die leiter der wahllokale und
das ist idealerweise auch noch die
richtigen stimmzettel für das jeweilige
wahllokal sind da sie also auch den
kandidaten den ich auf dem plakat
gesehen hat wählen kann auch das war ein
bisschen schwierig und dann hatten wir
das größte logistische probleme die
sache mit den wagen möglicherweise kennt
jeder berliner dass es so viel bis zum
wahlurnen pro wahllokal jetzt aber weil
es ja ganz so dramatisch war stichwort
pandemie man muss das mit dem richtigen
tremolo in der stimme sagen damalige
pandemie da macht man dann mehr sondern
weniger nämlich im schnitt 2 und das
führte dann dazu dass wir stundenlange
warteschlangen vor den wahllokalen
hatten was wiederum natürlich ein
völliger eingriff in die freiheit und
gleichheit der wahl ist weil dann eben
halt jemand mit 85 bzw
ein mensch mit 93 der sich bei uns
gemeldet hat der hat sich mehrfach an
gestellt und konnte dann eben halt nicht
wählen weil er dann irgendwann nach
einer stunde mal wieder nach hause gehen
musste und dann kamen wir irgendwann
nach 18 uhr an und da hat man mir jetzt
ist aber auch zu spät es dürften also
auch menschen die ein wahlrecht haben
nicht wählen auf der anderen seite haben
wir eine staatliche versicherung
vorgelegt von menschen die gewählt haben
obwohl sie nicht fehlen durften den man
einfach mal die falschen stimmzettel
gegeben hat und dann haben wir das ist
noch mal mein liebling eigentlich weil
das zu viel sagt darüber wie diese stadt
hier geführt wird dann haben wir die
vielen menschen die den demokratie und
politik so wichtig ist dass sie sogar
noch aus dem graben gewählt haben wir
haben einen großen teil von menschen die
stimmzettel erst mal
wahlbenachrichtigungen bekommen haben
die längst verstorben sind und
irgendjemand hat ihr dann offensichtlich
mal genutzt briefwahlunterlagen gestellt
und dann haben wir diesen tollen
demokratischen kontrolle prozess dann
kontrolliert der der entsprechende
wahlvorstand kontrolliert dann eben halt
ob dieses ding auch von den menschen
unterschrieben ist blöderweise kenne ich
aber herr meier müller schulz ja
überhaupt nicht so und dann ist da eben
halte krakelt runter dann werde ich den
falschen da ein und schon haben wir
leute die gewählt haben und der grund
warum wir so viele tote haben die
tatsächlich noch benachrichtigt werden
ist liegt im klaren berliner problem des
länderfinanzausgleichs wenn wir das
wirklich mal an das bereinigen würden
wer die stadt schon wieder um noch
einige zehntausend leute ärmer im
länderfinanzausgleich und deswegen war
das auch ungünstig ja und
dementsprechend als das alles
zusammenkam und dazu auch als man noch
eine vielzahl von anderen
merkwürdigkeiten die am wahltag passiert
sind auch wallonen die zwischenzeitlich
mal geöffnet wurden um schon mal so ein
bisschen voraus zu zählen gegen 15 uhr
und als solche dönekes habe ich eben
halt die wahl als erster seiner zeit
angefochten und habe das sowohl vor dem
landesverfassungsgerichtshof als auch
vor dem wahlprüfungsausschuss des
deutschen bundestages mit knapp 4 nach
drei jahren hat ja heute der
bundeswahlleiter in einer
ausschusssitzung das wahlkomitee ist im
deutschen bundestag gesagt also in
mindestens sechs stimmbezirken in berlin
müsse zumindest die bundestagswahl
nachgeholt werden und daraus leitet bei
in berlin dann auch ab das würde
bedeuten natürlich müsste die ganze
landtagswahl in berlin auch wiederholt
werden
die frage wie lange haben sie an
gestanden an dem wahlsonntag gegend die
unter sehr früh hingegangen in einem
wahllokal war ich auch gleich drin hab
gewählt und bilder rausgegangen das
heißt ich habe alles was danach gekommen
ist erstaunt zur kenntnis genommen aber
bei mir lief auch dir der der marathon
vorbei da war mir schon klar hier kommt
ja noch niemand mehr durch um
irgendwelche wahlzettel hin zu fahren
oder so das jahr 2010 war der marathon
allerdings auch bei basis tags ja das
alleine ist ja aber da gab es keinen
anlass weil es waren zu wenig
stimmzettel in den in den wahllokalen da
muss noch welche hin transportiert
werden es ging eben dann alles nicht
also einmal klar zu machen was da
passiert ist einen solchen skandal hat
es in deutschland noch nie gegeben und
trotzdem ist jetzt acht monate her hat
weder das landesverfassungsgericht noch
der wahlprüfungsausschuss des bundestags
bestimmtes muss neu gewählt werden das
hängt immer noch acht monate
und wenn die jetzt noch ein paar monate
darüber beraten es gebe ja auch kein
interesse man muss es ja mal sagen also
die regierende koalition in berlin die
kann ja der rot grüne senat kann ja gar
kein interesse an einer neuwahl ein auge
frei aber vielleicht sagen ein zwei
vielleicht sogar ihr amt verlieren dass
er natürlich haben die grünen lassen
könnten die nächste regierung die bürger
noch nicht abgeschlagen aber ganz klar
die spd hat kannte den ich aber das
gericht selben tag übrigens gericht
selbst hat ein interesse denn es werden
keine neuen richtern nachberufen durch
ein parlament was möglicherweise gar
nicht korrekt berufen worden ist dann
ist auch die richterwahl wieder zum
teufel dh die hängen da selber dran
alles was parlamente zu tun hängt an
dieser entscheidung und ich finde nach
acht monaten die vorstellung dass in dem
landesparlament von berlin menschen
sitzen die gar nicht gewählt worden sind
die da nicht hingehören und andere die
eigentlich rein gehören draußen bleiben
müssen es doch eine art treiber thomas
kneisel das hätte auch in düsseldorf
ganz genauso passieren können oder nicht
das ist um es mal klar zu sein das ist
zynismus nachgerade also jedem daraus
ist ja meiner führung von düsseldorf
wäre es nicht was sagen sie jetzt halten
gut mehr als eben so sagen es gab bei
der kommunalwahl mit dem hohen briefwahl
anteil da gab es auch ein paar probleme
in der tat dass ein paar briefe eben
nicht mehr rechtzeitig angekommen sind
wir reden über ganz andere pensionen
wobei ich in der tat sagen muss wenn
hier die wahl angefochten wird dann muss
das gericht darüber entscheiden das ist
dann letztlich eine frage ob die wahl
tatsächlich rechtmäßig verfassungsgemäß
zustande gekommen ist und wenn das nicht
der fall ist wurde er muss man natürlich
sich überlegen
man kann ja nicht die wahl vernichtet
erklären denn das würde bedeuten dass
all das was von dem parlament das in der
wahl gewählt wurde beschlossen wurde
auch nicht da wobei auch nicht ständig
muss man so sagen da ist sehr üblich
dass das verfassungsgericht zeigt wenn
bestimmte regelungen nicht
verfassungsgemäß sind dann setzt man
eine frist für eine neuregelung und hebt
sozusagen nicht die vergangenheit auf
also angemessen
natürlich wenn wenn die anfechtung
erfolgreich ist dann muss es nicht eine
wiederholung der wahl sondern eine
frühzeitige neuwahl geben dass eben
tatsächlich im ergebnis einer dann auch
nicht regulären mal nein sagen
legitimiertes parlament zustande
gekommen das problem ist doch wenn ich
neuwahlen beziehungsweise eine
wahlwiederholung bekomme dann bekomme
ich die deshalb weil ich sage dass
diesem parlament diesen 19 abgeordnete
aus wie es jetzt zusammen sitzt die
demokratische legitimation fehlt weil es
nicht aus freien gleichen und geheimen
wahlen hervorgegangen ist und wenn ich
also dann ein salopp gesagt räuber
parlament habe das irgendwie da
plötzlich sitzt dann kann ich doch nicht
sagen einerseits seid ihr nicht
demokratisch legitimiert und müsste
deshalb weg aber macht noch mal ein
bisschen weiter ich hatte das in meiner
anfechtung auch in dem ich habe ja
damals auch vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht ein zwei jahren
ordnung beantragt zu verhindern dass
dieses 19 abgeordnetenhaus sich
konstituiert bis die vorwürfe aufgeklärt
sein der ja auch kein problem wir hatten
ja ein parlament das achtzehnte
abgeordnetenhaus das unstreitig dass ein
anleger dazu sagen wenn schon nicht
demokratisch legitimiert ist und ob das
jetzt noch mal ein halbes jahr länger
arbeitet oder nicht ist ja nicht schlimm
der des 19 sie verliert ja nichts die
legislaturperiode dauert dann ja auch
wieder fünf jahre so hält das
verfassungsgericht selbst war einfach
stolz
jemand rein marktbeobachterin als
wählerin die jetzt nicht direkt in
demokratische prozesse eingreifen weil
sie nicht abgeordnete waren aber wie
wirkt das auf sie wenn sie das sehen
hören was hier in berlin passiert ist
und aber auch den streit unter
politikern dazu mitbekommen also ich
finde das auch ein verheerendes signal
das man so schlampig sozusagen mit mit
einem solchen fehler umgeht und sich
dann weiter durch wo steht und sagt so
naja war halt jetzt um die blöd aber
gucken wir mal ob wir eine neuwahl
machen oder nicht und dann sehen wir
weiter ich halte das wirklich für gift
für eine demokratie und aus meiner sicht
ist auch so zu sagen dass das vertrauen
in die demokratie einen rechtsstaat in
den letzten jahren schon an
verschiedenen stellen massiv beschädigt
worden und das führt dazu dass parteien
wie die afd zuwachs zulauf bekommen das
ist die folge von fehlern von spd und
cdu über jahre aus meiner sicht und nur
auf die afg zb einzudreschen finde ich
extrem billig und das führt auch zu
einem ganz großen teil von nichtwählern
also zum beispiel in der nrw wahl wenn
ich mehr als 40 sind überhaupt nicht so
weit gegangen dass die größte fraktion
ist die der nichtwähler und das ist für
eine kleine luke demokratie ein
armutszeugnis sind wir in berlin sind
wir in berlin schon so viele pannen
desaster debakel gewöhnt dass es sowas
gibt wie eine ich sag's mein auto steht
egal stimmung hier also das ist berlin
und das lässt uns alles gerne slow was
die öffentliche verwaltung angeht ist
komplett verschlampt und daran hat man
sich über viele jahre gewöhnt dass
regiert ja auch immer die gleiche
koalition weiter die hat nichts geändert
wenn man einen neuen ausweis braucht
also oder einen neuen pass braucht man
ein jahr bis man den terminen am bürger
am krieg sind alles zu halten alle
berlins bundesverdienstkreuz erklärer
leider fähigkeit ich wollte oder wir
holen hier bleiben sind inzwischen hat
das landesverfassungsgericht ja die
schriftlichen unterlagen von mehr als
wahllokalen
bestellt und bekommen und wenn man da
rein guckt sie kennen die alle ich kenne
nur ein bisschen was davon dann stellt
man fest dass das wird ja immer
schlimmer da durch das sind
herausgerissene seiten das sind kugel
schreiber schmierigen das sind
unleserliche notizen das sind aber auch
ein paar sehr wertvolle dinge die man da
ablesen ich will ein beispiel erzählen
in friedrichshain ein wahllokal morgens
um 8 eröffnet um viertel nach acht
stellen sie fest sie haben die falschen
stimmzettel bekommen die rufen bei der
wahlleitung an und sagen wir haben die
falschen stimmzettel die sagen ihn gibt
die mal ruhig weiter aus glas tun sie
ritalin und zwei stunden später moment
zwei stunden später kriegen sie den
anruf die dürfen sie aber nicht werten
die sind ungültig das heißt das sind die
stimmen von 82 menschen in den mülleimer
geworfen worden ohne dass diese 82
menschen davon was erfahren haben durch
seine unfähigkeit einer wahlfeier es
gebe deutlich sagen sie dass die wahl
wiederholt werden muss die landtagswahl
in berlin
absolut und israel ist wird sie
wiederholt ja ich bin davon überzeugt
weil das nicht geht ich glaube sie wird
anfang kommenden jahres wiederholt
thomas kaiser wird wiederholt es gibt
frühzeitig neuwahlen deswegen weil
dieses wahlergebnis zu recht angefragt
frau stolze und sie sind auch da man ja
also also wir sind hier der meinung 15
01 täglich 100 prozent die frage hier
kann man als landtagswahl wird
wiederholt bei allen verkehrsunternehmen
sind auch seine mama ist wahrscheinlich
da steht das berliner wahlrecht im weg
dadurch dass wir sowohl bezirks als auch
landeslisten bei den parteien haben
kriegen sie ein solches kunden model
weil sie eben ja irgendwo der regen habe
verändert sich alles durch möchte noch
eines sagen das ist verfassungsrechtlich
nur weil es ist in der tat mich hat das
massiv gestört dass das
verfassungsgericht schon nicht
eingegriffen hat beim zusammentreten
dieses 19 abgeordneten aus ist und was
mich jetzt wirklich überrascht hat ist
dass die von der spd nominierte
präsidentin dieses verfassungsgerichts
die frau selting offensichtlich eben
auch kein interesse hat jetzt das
verfahren zu beschleunigen oder auch die
öffentlichkeit herzustellen das
verwaltungsgericht düsseldorf hat vor
jahren entschieden dass
selbstverständlich diese unterlagen
öffentlich sind und
der verfassungsgerichtshof die
präsidentin beklagt sich dass wir diese
unterlagen und veröffentlichen und
presse öffentlich machen das ist ja wohl
ein witz ja wo ist also das thema wird
uns noch beschäftigen wird mutmaßlich im
juni eine entscheiden wann ein hier
leben
es gibt eine vorgezogene neuheiten